Oh y'all know about moon boy I'm sure
you all watch moved by some incredible
so it comes at in Ireland in the 90s
twelve-year-old boy and his adult
Imaginary Friends huge success two books
I don't now the second the fish
detective actually is out next week star
producer Chris O'Dowd is here as if you
needed any introduction along with Nick
Vincent Murphy there I say good morning
hello good just good to see you both
thank you it's pretty it's Chris it's
very strange seeing you in the flesh
actually because you're always on the
telly whether it's Mumbai or you know
one of the comedy panel shows whatever
it is you're always at you always on
screen boy when you flick through the
EPG and you know you're on every channel
I like many members of the public
I'm tired of the size of my own space
we're coming to the end of a book tour
where we've kind of you know it's more
it feels like you're on all the time but
really it's just like one week a year
where people have to endure the ignominy
of my face about fish detective this is
the second book how did the first one go
it was a successful presumably a
pleasure we'll be bringing that second
yeah yeah I mean great do you think we
call yes it was terrible here we are
though
yes no it went wonderfully well you
never know
career yes to breakthrough the truth no
it was we won the Irish Book Awards with
yeah and yeah went I really went well
with the kids and its really for like
ages 8 plus and the first one that
blunder years and now this one the fish
detective which is kind of more of a
Christmas story and so it kind of takes
place in the the lead-up to Christmas
and Martin Moone is really wants to get
a Game Boy for Christmas and but he
can't afford it his parents are broken
so he decides to get a job and so he
gets the job as a butcher boy in the
local town but the butchers are
struggling because the fish shop across
the road is doing wonderful business
everybody that year and boy wanted a
festive fish Christmas haddock and
they're producing these beautifully
fillers of fish as rock-bottom prices
but nobody knows why so he infiltrates
the local fish factory and discovers a
wonderful mystery with the whole moon
boy thing sort of phenomenon with the
work so this just something is it the
fact that it is set slightly back in
time and it just has that it does have
it might only be sought 20 years but
it's still got that real nostalgic feel
about it I think there's a touch of
nostalgia to it and I think the show has
got a lot of heart but isn't too pushy
about us you know it's not saccharine
but I think it is kind of sweet and it's
not really that many shows the families
can genuinely watch together and and I
think this bit obviously the book is
written for a slightly younger audience
but we have people who can parents all
the time saying that they'll kind of
steer off their kids oh yeah I can't
believe it and it's essentially there
for humor isn't it because it's not
straightforward it's not sort of
slapstick all right and up comedy it's
quite well it's quite sophisticated as
well yeah I you know what I think that's
true which is somewhat self-serving but
I do think that it's it's smart I mean
it's it's well I think we veer between
kind of clever listen and silliness all
the time yeah don't we yeah but even the
silly stuff isn't it's not just
pratfalls and stuff it's it's it's
surrealism you said you said just as he
did a full perfect but yeah I won't
think about it as the universe of the
universe of Dalek it's very Universal so
it means like it's about a small kid
growing up in a small town and so it's
shown around the world you know because
a lot of people can identify with that
you know so moonboys shown in like New
Zealand and Russia and Norway and
everywhere you know and even the books
are being translated into different
languages in terms of writing yeah how
difficult is it to put pen to paper you
know what with a batter book with the
book and and having to carry on what the
characters are doing on screen and and
how they're portrayed how the actors are
doing it is it difficult is it just flow
I don't quite get you well in terms of
the character eyes
Oshin keeping it going on the page
because presumably you've got to write
it thinking that the viewers are gonna
the readers are gonna read it and think
of you oh I see yeah sorry yeah yeah I
think to an extent that's probably true
but also there will be people who read
the book because of its age group that
aren't hugely familiar with the show and
also if they think of me that's okay
like it's not like we're saying this is
a completely different character to the
person that you've seen on the
television show and you know I've kind
of co-written it so it's kind of my
voice coming through a lot anyway and we
do bring up new characters in the book
so people have to stretch their
imaginations a bit more anything
exciting anything exciting that we
should be looking for to in terms of new
characters it quite a variation from
what we've seen before
well what we get into in this book is we
kind of wanted to get in to last kind of
a small social message that when we
started writing it it was in the lead up
to the last general election and the
world immigrant was being thrown around
a loss like it was a curse word and what
Nick and I are immigrants so we found
that kind of offensive so we kind of we
deal with immigration in a local
community in a big way in this in this
book and how that is viewed from the
eyes of a child and the ridiculous
nature of our own prejudices at times
joking talking prejudices I wonder what
what's the view in Ireland in the sense
that the portrayal of Ireland in that in
that rural 90s slightly backward setting
does that cut any cause ever cause any
eruptions at all or do people in Ireland
just say well that's how it was well I
think people in Ireland are smart enough
to know that it's set in the past so
it's not like we're in some way depicted
as backward it's just it's a historical
piece yeah fair enough right and I have
to say my favorite scene ever was that
thing with the dress and the toilet duck
and the been there we have over there
you can see the logic you
great to see you both this we all knew
and the set of books out next week to be
out today so today we've got a shop
that's right and have you brought any in
with you
we've got 12 none for you guys
unfortunately ya know we've got load for
you backstage I thought you're gonna say
no then so you complete take of the wind
out of my sails guys good to see very
much